A
PLATFORM, IT ALL COMES TUMBLING
DOWN.
CHARLES PAYNE, HOST OF MAKING
MONEY WITH CHARLES PAYNE ON
FOX BUSINESS, UNDERSTANDS THIS.
HE'S BEEN WATCHING THIS SINCE
THE BEGINNING AND DOING WHAT WE
CANNOT DO, WHICH IS ASSESSING IT
AS A BUSINESS PLAY WE ARE HAPPY
TO HAVE THEM JOIN US NOW.
CHARLES, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
WHAT YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> YOU KNOW, I WISH I COULD GO
THROUGH EVERY ONE OF THOSE
THINGS YOU TALKED ABOUT.
FOR INSTANCE, THE FOLKS ON CNN,
I FEEL LIKE THEY'VE NEVER EVEN
BEEN TO A GARAGE SALE.
I MEAN, YEAH, HE'S NEGOTIATING,
ELON MUSK, MSNBC, FREELOADER,
YOU GOT TO BE KIDDING ME.
YOU GOT 99,000 EMPLOYEES AND
HE'S BRINGING FACTORIES BACK TO
AMERICA.
SO FROM A BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE,
YOU'VE GOT A GUY WHO SOLD THE
BUSINESS FOR $176 MILLION.
WHAT THEY DO?
HE PLOWED EVERY SINGLE NICKEL
INTO TWO PIPE DREAMS.
ONE WAS CALLED TESLA, ONE WAS
CALLED SPACEX.
THE VERY SAME PEOPLE THAT ARE
SAYING HE'S UNSOPHISTICATED
TODAY ARE THE SAME ONES WHO SAID
HE COULDN'T MAKE IT DOWN.
FAST-FORWARD TO HIS WEALTH
NETWORK BEING $276 BILLION RIGHT
NOW, AND YOU KNOW, THE NOTION OF
FREE SPEECH IN AMERICA EVER
BECOMING CONTROVERSIAL IN ITSELF
TELLS YOU WE ARE IN A DANGEROUS
PLACE.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE
QUOTE-UNQUOTE "ORANGE MAN."
LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT THE ORANGE
MAN.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ELECTED
TWITTER STOCK WAS $16 A SHARE.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP LEFT OFFICE
IT WAS $77 A SHARE AND PROMPTLY
WENT INTO FREE FALL.
THIS IS A COMPANY THAT REALLY
HAS SHOT THEMSELVES IN THE FOOT.
THEY ARE LOSING BIG TIME, THEY
NEED FRESH THINKING OUT THERE AT
ELON MUSK IS THE RIGHT MEDICINE.
IF THE RIGHT MEDICINE FROM A
BUSINESS PERSPECTIVE AND IT
CERTAINLY IS THE RIGHT MEDICINE
FOR THE ETHOS, FOR THE
FOUNDATION THAT AMERICA WAS
FOUNDED ON.
>> Tucker: REALLY QUICK, DO
YOU THINK MUSK UNDERSTANDS
WHAT'S ABOUT TO HAPPEN TO HIM?
THEY ARE GOING TO TRY AND CRUSH
HIM FOR REAL.
>> HE DOES, BECAUSE EVERYTHING
HE HAS DONE, TUCKER, THEY HAVE
TRIED TO CRUSH HIM.
THEY HAVE TRIED TO CRUSH TESLA
AT EVERY TURN.
THE WHITE HOUSE HATES TESLA
BECAUSE IT'S A NONUNION SHOP.
THEY HAVE TRIED TO BEAT HIM DOWN
EVERY SINGLE WAY THEY CAN.
HE KNOWS THE CHALLENGE -- BY THE
WAY, THAT'S WHAT HE MADE IT
54.20 BURIED HE KNEW THEY WOULD
MAKE FUN OF IT, BUT THAT'S HOW
ELON MUSK OPERATES.
SAYS COME AT ME, BABY, BECAUSE
HE IS A WINNER AND GUESS WHAT,
ALL THEY HAVE IS OPINIONS.
>> Tucker: IF THIS WORKS AND
TWITTER IS OPENED UP TO
FREE SPEECH AND ELI MUSK IS
STILL STANDING A YEAR FROM NOW,
IT WILL BE A DIFFERENT COUNTRY